welcome to my childhood holy I so
got out of screening a movie and then I
got blown up on Twitter like Jurassic
world I'm gonna be honest with you guys
you know you can always rely on me to be
honest with you there's me being honest
I want to talk about the Jurassic world
trailer more than I want to talk about
Horrible Bosses 2 right now so I'm gonna
talk about the Jurassic world trailer
rather than Horrible Bosses 2 right now
just look at that review but it's
Jurassic Park orc world so the Jurassic
world trailer opens up his mom's talking
to her kids and she's like I'm so glad
you're going on this trip and if
something chases you remember right I
was like his mother of the year over
here sending her kids to Jurassic Park
alone then they go to the boat ride to
Jurassic world it's called Jurassic
world now and the park is open somehow
opened up to the public that's right the
entire world and the Internet slept
through the colossal that was
Jurassic Park but not the movie because
the movie is awesome I'm talking about
the protocols and procedures of the
actual parking within the movie itself
and the whole Godzilla segment in
Jurassic Park 2 that pretty much showed
people that dinosaurs just slaughter the
out of people that you probably
shouldn't make a park with them but we
can still make a park and call it a
world so now they've done it I thought
that was really cool I liked seeing John
Hammonds vision you're like oh
that's what what Jurassic Park would
have been nowadays and that's what your
Isaac Park would have been nowadays it's
a bunch of scenes harkening back to
Jurassic Park like the Gallimimus is
running through the field the
Brachiosaurus now look huge and as
I felt like I was even a scene where the
notes start coming on so I'm like you
know shit's gonna get screwed up as the
dinosaurs are gonna break out not just
any dinosaur a new dinosaur a genetic
Frankenstein compilation of other
dinosaurs to make this super evil
dinosaur it's now gonna go through the
park and start like chewing people up
not gonna like right there that's
wouldn't the magic kind of drop for me
and I was like you don't know maybe
that's my step kick coming up I just
don't know about that I wanted to
go to Jurassic Park to see what I saw
before in that I'm fine if Jurassic
world is pretty much a rehash of the
first movie which it looks like it's
gonna be see dinosaurs and dinosaurs
breakout and dinosaurs start killing
people and we all have to live through
it but now there's a whole park full of
people so it's still a little different
it has the same basic plot elements I
mean Terminator 2 is pretty much
the same plot of Terminator 1 but
Terminator 2 is just more than
Terminator 1 not nostalgic Lee this
isn't going to be more
Jurassic Park it's just not well that
genetic hybrid thing I just feel like
that's some AVP Requiem right there
it's like oh you've already seen what
the creatures can be before but so now
we have to combine them and make a super
creature that you don't have to run from
I could be wrong about that this could
be a really cool ass dinosaur it looks
like it's gonna be a hybrid of t-rex
meets Velociraptor it's probably gonna
be a lot more the probably gonna be like
7 different things I'm just saying my
Jurassic world if I could pick dinosaurs
to splice together you know and make
really bad decisions I'd splice to your
ex and Velociraptor even Chris Pratt and
the trailers like probably not a good
idea plus in the trailer Chris press
like that thing's gonna kill anyone that
moves gnomes like oh so is it direction
so that's how he was in Jurassic Park I
get within the marketing of the Jurassic
world within the movie itself we're
talking like the characters I get why
they would make a new dinosaur they're
like everyone's already seen everything
maybe they're gonna touch on like all
sales are down ten percent from last
year we have to do something bigger all
right let's genetically cross dinosaurs
and make new dinosaurs I can see that
happening in the world so I can see
it happening in this movie so there is
that I just hope it's not like welcome
to Jurassic world all the dinosaurs the
magic the nostalgia the Sharktopus as my
fear and it might be unwarranted fear
but I'm just a cautious person there is
this one shot in the trailer where Bryce
Dallas Howard this door opens up and she
has a flyer and she looks like she's
ready to flash where is she looks like
Ripley from aliens yes see at the end
with Chris Pratt riding his motorcycle
with the velociraptors he might be
running from the velociraptors they
don't seem to be too concerned with him
I'm like I heard in the movie he's some
behavior analyst for dinosaurs so I
imagine he's gonna be like well I know
how they act and if you do this they're
not gonna kill you but if you're going
away from velociraptors and going fast
but not faster than velociraptors
wouldn't velociraptors kind of see you
as prey at that point pretty much how
things that are going to get eaten by
velociraptors act that run away from
them not as fast as them and get caught
I'm analyzing two minutes a trailer
footage guys I'm really not bitching
about it these are just the questions
these are the questions that people
should ask that's what I got from the
Jurassic world trailer there were parts
that made - Dalek head explode there
were other parts that made me go I hope
they tread carefully on that because I
don't want this to be a generic monster
movie whatever the case I'm gonna end up
seeing the movie because it's Jurassic
world what earth dude holy a lot of
those action figures when I was a kid
I'd like the baby t-rex that you choke
his mouth opens up his alive
seriously this movie's not going to be
better than mine rip his flesh away
and I say had I meant have versa the
Jurassic world trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more objects in mirror are
closer than they appear